so I remember this scene I remember this
being one of our first scenes together
yeah yeah this was our first day
together and it was really you know one
that would set the tone of the entire
relationship but to be honest my memory
is about how much Lily affected this
entire scene we need to be quiet for a
while I I remember now looking at the
red corn fan family's uh antique SPO
dishes which they finally got back that
that year at elanka they were feeding
people off of rented plates but these
have been the plates this family has
used for the last hundred years to feed
people I remember asking when I had a
list of what would Molly be serving
Ernest and chose the grape dumplings I
was just about to say the grape
dumplings don't you want to B this I got
too much sugar I decided that I'm going
to serve him what has the most sugar
sugar in it as a
diabetic because you know it's just kind
of knowing that that's probably what he
was there for can never be too sweet now
can
you makes me sickly identifying him as
somebody that you know is after
something but she's also sitting in the
same room with him flirting with him
courting him getting to know him and
it's really the culmination of what to
me has been one of the most bizarre and
twisted love stories I've ever been a
part of um and and also this the element
of that you were talking about with this
with the storm as well that was your
input storm it's
a well it's
powerful so we need to be quiet for a
while when the storm would blow through
like that it's uh powerful so you need
to sit
kind of in reverence of it you need to
sit and receive what it's bringing to
remain quiet through all of that and my
my characters sort of still reaching for
the Whiskey Still reaching for the
drinks still wanting to drink still
wanting to relate still wanting to have
small talk yeah and I remember that
being you know you're the one who came
up with this idea for the line about it
it's good for the crops that's for sure
well it'll be good for the crops so it's
yeah kind of doing that Blackbird talk
thing feeling the silence and me just
creating it and allowing it to sit and I
remember talking to Marty too about just
sitting because often times when you do
these scenes are like what do I do next
exactly he had he had to articulate
quite a few times us no no no just sit
and watch the storm it's good for the
crops that's for sure just be
still